[Musik]
und wie war das gespräch mit deinen
eltern freuen sich weil es mir gut geht
ich wünsche mir viel glück und sie
lieben mich sehr der gleich nein sie
sind stinksauer
wütend ja sie sind wütend weil ich nicht
mehr studieren will sie sind wütend weil
ich nicht zurückkommen will und ich
bleibe hier
ok gehen wir nach hause
ok
ich muss zur bank gehen weil ich ein
konto eröffnen will
sehr gut du musst dich jetzt noch vieles
kümmern
ich kann heute nicht zur bank gehen weil
ich zu dieser zum sprachkurs gehen muss
um die viele musst du zu liter ich gehe
um 11 zu lisa dann kannst du danach zur
bank gehen das schaffst du
hier
ein willkommensgeschenk
damit geht schneller ok